as an app developer you don't think of
monetization at the end of when you
build the app you should really be
thinking monetization when you first are
thinking about building your app I met
this amazing app developer in the Bay
Area who built a game and he came to
talk to us recently he said you know I
have to start all over again we were
kind of scratching her husband said why
so I never thought about building the
brakes inside the game for where an ad
would actually sit he's like I have to
kind of start over and think about okay
you know where maybe in this level we'll
put one here and you know maybe during
where it shows the scores and all of
that so he had to actually go back and
redo his game which was unfortunate but
it just shows you that when you are
thinking about monetization or even just
building your app in the first place
think about the future don't think about
right then and there think about what
you really want to get out of your app
and you know in the long term